"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Tahar Ben Jelloun,
on sait que les relations
entre les responsables
de la France et du Maroc
sont actuellement
un peu tendues.
C'est le moins que l'on puisse dire.
Et pourtant,
les deux pays,
les deux peuples
entretiennent une amitié
qui est assez singulière,
un peu différente de ce qui existe,
par exemple, entre la France
et l'Algérie.
-Tout à fait, d'autant plus
que les deux peuples
s'apprécient, s'estiment...
ont des relations amicales.
Là, nous vivons une crise
qui vient d'en haut,
au niveau
des deux chefs d'Etat.
-Oui.
-Je crois que c'est la première fois
qu'on vit une crise aussi grave,
due, pour dire
les choses clairement,
aux maladresses
du président Macron...
-Oui.
-...qui n'a pas compris
à qui il avait affaire.
-Vous parlez de Mohamed VI.
-Oui, Mohamed VI.
Dès le départ,
dès qu'il est arrivé
à l'Elysée,
ça, je l'ai su par les amis
qui travaillent avec lui,
il a donné priorité
au dossier algérien.
-Oui.
-Et il a voulu réussir
là où ses prédécesseurs
ont échoué.
C'est-à-dire que lui
va être plus fort.
Il va faire l'impossible :
que la page franco-algérienne
se tourne...
-Oui.
-...et qu'on établisse
des relations normales,
sans culpabilité,
sans rente mémorielle, etc.
-Sans ressentiment.
-Il se trompe.
-Oui.
-Il se trompe et...
Le Maroc n'a jamais
culpabilisé personne.
Et il avait en face de lui
un monarque,
qui n'est pas un monarque
symbolique,
c'est un monarque
qui gouverne,
qui a une légitimité
depuis des siècles
et qui est adoré
par le peuple marocain.
-C'est le royaume chérifien.
-Réellement,
le peuple adore son roi.
Du temps de son père,
c'était autre chose, mais là,
Mohamed VI,
il est beaucoup aimé.
Et il n'a pas compris
comment on parle à un roi.
-Oui.
-Enfin, bon.
Tout est parti
des écoutes...
-Pegasus.
-Pegasus !
-C'est-à-dire
qu'il accuse, justement,
la monarchie marocaine
de l'avoir écouté,
avec un système israélien,
d'ailleurs.
-D'abord,
tous les Etats du monde
s'écoutent les uns les autres.
-Ils se surveillent, oui.
-Tout le monde
s'écoute.
Mais là n'est pas la question.
Il a accusé le roi
de l'avoir fait écouter,
spécialement lui.
Le roi lui a dit :
"Je vous donne ma parole
que je ne vous ai
pas fait écouter.
Macron lui dit :
"J'ai des preuves."
Le roi lui répète :
"Je ne vous ai pas
fait écouter" et là,
il lui dit quelque chose
de très désagréable,
qu'on ne dit ni à un chef d'Etat,
ni à un premier ministre,
ni à personne.
Il a été
très désobligeant.
-Vis-à-vis du roi.
-Le roi a arrêté
la discussion net.
-Comment vous expliquez
qu'avec le président Trump,
le Maroc a signé
ce qu'on a appelé
les accords d'Abraham,
c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont renoué
des relations diplomatiques,
avec Israël, aussi,
en échange de quoi
les Etats-Unis reconnaissent...
-La marocanité...
-...la marocanité
du Sahara occidental,
mais pas la France.
Ca a joué entre les deux pays ?
-Un peu, parce qu'il n'était pas
au courant.
Il n'a pas été mis au courant
et en fait,
ceux qui ont le plus travaillé
les accords d'Abraham,
ce sont quelques Israéliens.
-Oui.
-Trump ne connaît pas bien
le dossier,
le Maroc, mais il a dit :
"OK, banco."
D'autant plus qu'après,
il y a les Emirats Arabes, etc.
et Israël a bien joué.
Et ça a été,
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait,
ça a été très bien reçu
par le peuple marocain.
-Oui.
-D'abord, parce qu'on a vraiment
une très grande proximité
avec la communauté juive marocaine
qui est en Israël
et ailleurs dans le monde,
et qui revient souvent au Maroc,
en tant que touriste.
-Un des pays arabes qui a
l'une des plus grosses
communautés juives.
-Oui, qui a été
la plus grosse.
Maintenant, il y en a
à peu près 5000,
mais il y a
un million de touristes.
On a des choses
en commun.
On a beaucoup de...
On a une culture commune.
Une culture, une civilisation,
une cohabitation...
On n'a pas fait
la guerre.
C'est pas l'Egypte,
c'est pas la Jordanie,
c'est pas le Liban,
donc on a une relation,
disons... assez...
assez riche
et, finalement,
même si le roi
est président
du comité Qods, de Jérusalem,
on reste vigilant vis-à-vis
de la question palestinienne.
-C'est ça.
Je voudrais qu'on revienne...
On a parlé des dirigeants
des deux pays,
mais si on regarde bien
l'histoire des deux peuples,
justement,
c'est plutôt des bonnes relations,
puisque...
-Ca a toujours été
des bonnes relations,
même du temps...
-En 56, à l'indépendance,
on parlait
de l'"indépendance...
-"DANS L'INTERDEPENDANCE".
-Mais...
La première grande crise,
qui est, à mon avis, plus grave
que celle-ci,
c'est l'affaire Ben Barka
en octobre 65.
-Qui était un opposant au roi.
-De Gaulle l'avait très,
très mal pris.
C'est une histoire qui s'est
très, très mal passée
et qui s'est terminée
par la mort du pauvre Ben Barka.
-1965.
-Oui, 29 octobre.
Le roi avait demandé :
"Ramène-moi
"Mehdi."
-Mehdi Ben Barka,
opposant politique.
-Oui, il était opposant
et il était
son prof de maths.
Le roi n'a jamais dit :
"Tuez-moi Ben Barka."
Non, c'était pas son genre.
C'était pas ça.
Sauf que les Américains
craignaient beaucoup
ce personnage
qui s'agitait beaucoup,
qui avait des relations
avec la Tricontinentale,
la Havane,
la Yougoslavie, avec Nehru
et qui devenait
un personnage du Tiers-Monde
qui menaçait un peu
l'Amérique et la CIA.
On ne sait pas
ce qui s'est passé réellement.
On sait juste qu'il est mort
sous la torture
et son corps
a disparu.
Ca a fait un...
-En France.
Ca a fait
un très, très très grand choc.
Le général de Gaulle
était très en colère,
le roi Hassan II
était extrêmement
en colère, lui aussi,
mais on a fini
par ravoir
des relations normales.
Et la deuxième crise,
sous Hollande,
lorsque la police
a débarqué dans la résidence
de l'ambassadeur du Maroc.
-En France.
-Oui, toujours, à Neuilly,
pour signifier
un papier de police
ou de justice
pour le directeur marocain
de la DST,
poursuivi pour torture,
etc.
-Oui.
-Ca, ça a duré une bonne année.
-Ca a été considéré
comme une agression diplomatique.
-Ca se fait pas.
-Ca se fait pas, de rentrer
chez l'ambassadeur, comme ça.
Ca a été très maladroit
de la part des Français.
Les amis du Maroc et de la France,
comme Elisabeth Guigou
ont rétabli les choses,
après.
-Alors, la langue française
a beaucoup de lustre
au Maroc.
D'ailleurs,
les établissements français au Maroc
sont très fréquentés
par les Marocains.
-Alors, il faut quand même
tirer une sonnette d'alarme.
La langue française
commence un petit peu
à être malmenée
par les familles.
Il y a eu les histoires
des visas.
-Oui.
-C'est très maladroit.
-Elle n'est pas
très ancienne.
-Il n'est pas question
de venir s'installer en France
et de prendre le travail
des Français.
Des professeurs de médecine,
un procureur du roi,
un ancien ministre...
-Ils n'ont pas pu venir,
car ils n'ont pas
eu de visa
à cause de la décision
de diviser par deux
le nombre de visas
accordés aux Marocains.
-C'était une punition collective,
tout le Maghreb.
Ca, ce sont des choses
très maladroites,
qu'aucun régime avant Macron
n'aurait faites.
Bien sûr qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des visas,
pour savoir qui rentre, etc.
Mais quand vous avez
un procureur du roi qui demande
un visa pour X raison,
ou un ancien ministre,
il va pas venir pour...
pour occuper un poste.
C'était l'humiliation.
-Oui.
-Ca a été très mal perçu
par les Marocains.
Il y a eu aussi
une humiliation
à un niveau personnel,
l'un ancien ministre de l'Economie,
Moulay Hafid Elalamy,
qui est un milliardaire
et qui a beaucoup d'affaires,
dont des affaires en France,
et aux Etats-Unis.
Il est venu avec son jet privé
au Bourget pour régler ses affaires
et là,
application des lois stricte :
fouille systématique
pendant quatre heures,
du jet, de ses affaires,
de son ordinateur, de son téléphone,
fouille corporelle.
Ca a duré 4h ou 4h30.
Monsieur l'ancien ministre
a repris son jet
et est reparti au Maroc.
-C'est pas pour ça
que l'enseignement du français
recule.
-Il recule parce qu'à partir
d'octobre ou septembre,
l'anglais sera 2e langue
dans le collège.
-Après l'arabe.
Et donc...
-Donc, le recul.
-Vous le déplorez pas,
vous qui écrivez en français ?
-Bien sûr que je le déplore,
c'est pas que d'aujourd'hui.
La France n'a pas agi
pour défendre la langue française.
C'est le problème.
-Il y a des établissements
de langue française au Maroc,
gérés d'ailleurs par la France.
-Il y a des établissements
qui pratiquent
l'éducation française.
Massignon, par exemple.
-Le lycée Lyautey.
-Et les Marocains
se disputent
pour y mettre leurs enfants,
et ça coûte 500 euros,
5000 dirhams par enfant par mois.
C'est pas donné.
-C'est pas donné.
C'est la bourgeoisie qui peut
se le permettre.
-En même temps, on...
Il y a une espèce de désagrément
entre la France et le Maroc
qui a fait que certains ont commencé
à inscrire leurs enfants
dans les universités américaines
ou anglaises,
quand ils ont les moyens.
-Expliquez-moi pourquoi
les relations
entre le Maroc et l'Algérie
sont aussi détestables,
aussi compliquées.
Il m'est arrivé récemment
d'interviewer
le président algérien,
qui m'a répondu à une question :
"On a fermé la frontière
avec le Maroc
"pour ne pas se faire la guerre."
C'est terrible, ça.
-Il dit n'importe quoi,
celui-là.
Je vais vous raconter
une anecdote.
Sacha Guitry,
le grand Sacha Guitry,
il a une pièce qui passe,
et le lendemain,
il y a son secrétaire
qui appelle : "Maître,
ne lisez pas Le Figaro ce matin,
"il y a quelque chose de désagréable
sur votre pièce."
Sacha descend de son bureau
et dit :
"J'imagine que l'article a été écrit
par quelqu'un
"à qui nous avons rendu
service."
"Exactement, maître."
L'Algérie et le Maroc,
c'est ça.
Le Maroc a sacrifié
beaucoup de choses,
a été vraiment l'arrière-pays
pendant la guerre.
Il y a eu la réunion de Tanger
en 58,
où les trois partis
nationalistes,
le FLN, l'Istiqlal et le Destour
sont réunis à Tanger
pour voir l'avenir du Maghreb
dans l'esprit de l'indépendance
des trois pays
et d'un Maghreb uni,
dans un sens de progrès.
Il n'y avait ni islamisme,
ni rien.
Et se posait à l'époque
le problème de Tindouf,
ville marocaine,
qui, en 1932,
avait été annexée par la France
parce qu'il y avait du fer.
Comme l'Algérie était française,
on la met
dans le territoire français.
Ferhat Abbas dit à El Fassi,
qui lui pose la question :
"Une fois indépendant,
on vous rendra votre ville,
"c'est une ville marocaine.
Ca a commencé comme ça.
62, l'indépendance,
le Maroc était content.
65,
se pose le problème
de la frontière.
Il y a la guerre des Sables.
Avec Ben Bella.
La guerre des Sables.
Ils ont tout oublié.
Boumédiène prend le pouvoir
avec un coup d'Etat.
-A Alger, oui.
-Et en 74, il y a
le sommet islamique à Casa,
Casablanca, et là, le Maroc
fait voter une résolution
pour récupérer
les territoires sahariens
occupés par l'Espagne.
L'Espagne va quitter
le territoire au moment où Franco
était en train de mourir,
en 75.
Il y a la Marche verte.
On avance et on récupère
les territoires.
L'Algérie applaudit,
c'est formidable.
Boumédiène,
qui n'était pas à Casablanca,
Bouteflika le représentait,
se met en colère, il dit :
"Pas du tout,
"nous, on veut une sortie
sur l'Atlantique,
"donc on a besoin..."
-Du Sahara occidental.
-Ca a commencé comme ça.
-Et c'est comme ça que...
-Et Kadhafi donnait l'argent.
Il a financé le mouvement
dès le départ.
Après, Kadhafi n'a pas
voulu continuer.
Mais l'Algérie a continué
à financer, à armer
jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
-Donc vous considérez
que l'Algérie est un adversaire
dans le contexte régional ?
-Alors,
c'est extraordinaire, le peuple
algérien adore le Maroc.
Le Maroc n'a aucune animosité
à l'égard du peuple...
-C'est une histoire
de dirigeants.
entre une junte militaire
qui a besoin de ça
pour exister.
-Ouais.
Et puis un pays qui veut avoir
une intégrité territoriale.
-Vous parliez d'Hassan II
et de Mohammed VI.
Hassan II avait très bonne presse,
en France,
il avait une espèce
d'aisance oratoire,
il apparaissait souvent.
On le voit ici
en photo.
Il connaissait
la politique française
mieux que personne,
sans doute !
Mohammed VI, votre roi,
n'a pas la même image :
on le connaît moins bien.
Il apparaît moins souvent.
Et, euh...
Je crois, pour avoir lu,
vous avoir beaucoup lu,
et entendu,
qu'il y a une grande injustice
vis-à-vis de lui, non ?
-C'est-à-dire que lui,
contrairement
à son père,
il n'aime pas les médias
ou la communication.
-C'est ça, la différence.
-C'est-à-dire,
quand il fait
les discours officiels,
on voit que ça lui pèse.
-C'est dur.
-Mais il travaille beaucoup.
Il connaît tout ce qui se passe
en France et ailleurs.
Il est extrêmement informé
sur tout.
Et il est très bien disposé
à l'égard de...
à l'égard du peuple français,
en tout cas.
Il vient très, très,
très souvent en France.
Il a ses habitudes.
Il connaît
les meilleurs restaurants,
les meilleures librairies,
les meilleures
galeries de peinture,
parce qu'il adore l'art.
C'est quelqu'un
qui aime la France.
-On vous reproche parfois
d'être très royaliste, vous.
-Je suis avec le roi
à 100 %.
Je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Parce que,
lorsqu'il y a eu
le coup d'Etat en 1971,
le 10 juillet 1971,
il a été fait
par des officiers
et des sous-officiers
de l'armée marocaine,
que j'ai très bien connus.
J'avais 20 ans
et j'étais dans une prison
militaire marocaine.
Enfin, un camp disciplinaire
dirigé par ces gens-là.
Je sais pertinemment
ce qu'ils auraient fait du Maroc,
s'ils avaient réussi.
-Les putschistes.
-Ca aurait été l'Irak ou la Syrie,
ni plus ni moins.
-D'accord.
-C'était des brutes.
La plupart venaient
d'Indochine.
Ils y ont fait la guerre,
comme le fameux Akka,
qui a participé au coup d'Etat,
qui sera abattu à Kenitra.
Donc, je suis avec le roi,
parce qu'il travaille
beaucoup,
il aime son pays,
et il sert son pays.
-Vous, vous êtes...
De façon acharnée,
vous vous opposez,
et vous luttez
contre l'islamisme.
Vous avez beaucoup
écrit là-dessus.
Dans la presse...
-C'est pas la nature marocaine.
Nous avons un rite malikite
qui est très simple, très modéré.
En plus, les Frères musulmans,
au Maroc,
le PJD,
le Parti justice
et développement,
ont été deux fois au pouvoir
car le roi a respecté
la loi démocratique.
Comme en France.
Il n'y avait plus de trucage
ou de fraude, aux élections.
Ils ont gouverné 10 ans,
deux législatures
catastrophiques
et ils n'ont rien fait
pour le Maroc.
Ils essayaient un peu
de semer l'idéologie
des Frères musulmans
qui n'est pas
des plus progressistes.
-Ca a pas accroché ?
-Non.
-La menace est derrière nous ?
Derrière vous ?
-Pour le PJD,
c'est fini.
Quand, aux élections,
ils passent
de 125 députés à 13,
c'est énorme.
-Vous estimez que le Maroc...
-Il y a autre chose.
Il y a le terrorisme.
-Oui.
-On a une police efficace.
On a un peuple vigilant.
Tout le monde travaille
et surveille.
Toutes les semaines,
il y a un démantèlement
de cellule terroriste
ayant fait allégeance
à Daech.
On les prend,
on les met devant
des tribunaux
et on les met
en prison.
Et souvent,
les gens du quartier
les dénoncent.
Ils voient quelque chose qui va pas,
ils appellent la police.
Pourquoi ?
Un attentat, chez nous,
c'est la fin du tourisme.
-Bien sûr.
Je voudrais parler
de votre dernier livre.
Vous avez une bibliothèque
et un nombre de livres
absolument... Innombrable.
Je ne sais combien
vous en avez écrit,
depuis les années 60.
Vous passez par le prix Goncourt,
que vous avez eu,
avec la "Nuit sacrée",
qui est un livre magnifique.
Votre dernier livre,
sorti il y a peu,
un très joli titre,
"Les amants de Casablanca".
C'est une photographie,
me semble-t-il,
de ce qu'est
la société bourgeoise,
on va dire,
à un certain niveau,
marocaine.
Ca se passe à Casablanca.
C'est pas la capitale,
mais la grande
ville marocaine.
Voilà...
Entre une femme,
qui gagne très bien sa vie,
qui est pharmacienne,
qui a un amant,
et qui, d'ailleurs,
gagne mieux sa vie
que son mari.
Quand il est question
de divorce,
c'est elle qui doit payer
une pension et pas lui.
Est-ce que c'est le reflet
de la société marocaine ?
L'histoire de séparation,
ça, c'est un peu
partout pareil, mais...
Est-ce que
ce que vous décrivez là,
un mélange de tradition
et de modernité,
c'est ça, le Maroc d'aujourd'hui ?
-C'est le...
Comment dire ?
On est déchirés
entre, d'un côté,
les traditions marocaines
auxquelles on tient,
parce qu'elles font partie
de nos valeurs...
-Oui.
-...et puis,
cette modernité,
qui vient de l'Occident en général,
qui est la bienvenue
et qu'on veut partager
avec l'univers.
C'est-à-dire que,
finalement,
on veut être les deux,
un pied là et un pied là.
En même temps, on n'arrive pas
à trouver une espèce d'équilibre
et...
Et...
Le couple vit sur les deux.
-Oui.
-Et, parfois,
c'est de là que viennent
les difficultés.
-Est-ce que la société marocaine,
vous la sentez beaucoup évoluer ?
On dit qu'aujourd'hui,
elle a complètement changé
par rapport à ce qu'elle était.
-Alors...
Elle évolue, c'est vrai,
mais tant que le Parlement
n'a pas abrogé
deux articles de loi,
le 489 et le 490,
qui interdisent
l'homosexualité
et les relations sexuelles
hors mariage,
on ne peut pas dire
que le Maroc a changé.
Moi, je milite
pour l'abrogation de ces deux...
-Ces deux articles.
-Articles qui sont stupides,
d'autant plus qu'on ne va pas
condamner quelqu'un,
parce qu'il a
une sexualité différente.
C'est stupide.
Il a sa vie,
il est né comme ça,
on n'a pas à discuter.
Quant aux relations sexuelles
hors mariage,
il faut pas être sorcier
pour savoir
que tous les Marocains
font l'amour avant de se marier.
-Oui.
-C'est une réalité connue
et reconnue.
-Oui.
-En même temps,
ça permet à la police,
quand un jeune Marocain arrive
avec une jeune femme
à un hôtel, même 5-étoiles,
on lui dit :
"Qui c'est,
cette femme, là ?"
-"Vous n'avez pas
le droit de..."
-"Si c'est pas votre femme,
dehors, sinon...
"donnez-moi
l'acte de mariage."
-Oui.
-C'est arrivé
à des gens connus.
-Vous déplorez ça ?
-Mais bien sûr ! Et ça,
c'est les derniers...
Comment dire ?
Les derniers articles
auxquels s'accrochent
les islamistes,
parce qu'en ce moment,
il y a une révision
du code de la famille.
Il y a le commissaire
qui travaille.
Dans cette révision,
moi, je leur ai dit :
"Il faut absolument qu'on ait
la liberté de conscience",
Ils l'ont, les Tunisiens
et ils ne sont pas
meilleurs que nous.
Nous, on ne l'a pas.
Si on n'a pas ça,
l'évolution est un peu bancale.
-Vous vous estimez, vous,
écrivain franco-marocain,
comme un écrivain engagé ?
-Je suis un citoyen engagé.
-Vous êtes un citoyen engagé.
-La littérature engagée,
c'est pas très bon.
Non, je suis un citoyen,
je suis concerné par ce qui se passe
dans mes deux pays,
la France et le Maroc.
J'écris beaucoup,
toutes les semaines,
une chronique
dans Le 360,
qui est un peu proche
du pouvoir,
mais où je dis tout ce que je veux
avec liberté,
et qui est très lu,
et puis, ici, je critique
la politique française
quand ça ne va pas.
-Vous êtes
à l'Académie Goncourt
et vous avez,
il y a quelques années,
posé votre candidature
pour être à l'Académie française
et vous l'avez retirée !
-C'était avant.
-Pourquoi la retirer ?
-Je l'ai retirée,
parce que...
C'était presque fait,
mais un soir,
Alain Decaux,
mon ami et protecteur de l'époque,
m'a dit : "Tu laisses tomber."
"Pourquoi ?"
"Giscard veut le poste,
enfin le fauteuil."
-Ah oui.
-C'était pour Senghor.
C'est pas grave,
car l'Académie Goncourt,
on peut pas aller là-bas et nous,
à l'Académie Goncourt,
on rend service à la littérature
et on rend heureux quelques auteurs,
c'est très bien.
-Est-ce qu'il y a des écrivains
maghrébins qui vous ont inspiré
et/ou que vous admirez ?
-Ah bah, il y a Kateb Yacine,
d'abord.
-Kateb Yacine,
grand écrivain algérien.
-Mohammed Dib aussi.
-Mohammed Dib,
très, très grand écrivain algérien.
-Et puis Driss Chraïbi,
Hadibi, comme marocains.
Euh...
J'ai lu beaucoup
tous mes aînés.
Ils m'ont beaucoup apporté,
bien sûr.
-Et qu'est-ce que
vous retenez
de cette littérature
maghrébine ?
C'est souvent
une littérature de combat.
-C'est une littérature
de rébellion,
plutôt que de combat,
car beaucoup de femmes écrivent,
pour dire leur condition
insoutenable, insupportable,
et beaucoup de jeunes, aussi,
écrivent,
pour parler d'un Maroc
qui pourrait être bien mieux
que ce qu'il est actuellement.
Je parle de la pauvreté,
du niveau de la santé dans le pays,
de l'éducation...
Il y a des problèmes,
mais par ailleurs,
le roi,
il a fait le maximum,
il a doté le pays
d'infrastructures extraordinaires
et on a deux ports
sur la Méditerranée,
à Tanger,
qui sont exceptionnels,
les autoroutes, les TGV,
le...
A Ouarzazate, il a construit
une très grande centrale
pour capter le soleil.
-Une centrale
solaire.
-Il a fait beaucoup de choses
dans les directives.
Il y a le Parlement, le peuple,
c'est autre chose.
-Aujourd'hui,
le Maroc regarde beaucoup
vers l'Afrique subsaharienne.
-C'est important.
-Beaucoup d'investissements là-bas.
-Par amour de l'Afrique,
parce que Mohammed VI
adore l'Afrique
et il a un petit peu rectifié
une erreur de son père,
qui n'avait pas
une très grande proximité
en dehors de Senghor
et Boigny,
mais Mohammed VI,
il est allé
dans presque
tous les Etats africains,
il y a séjourné longtemps,
il a des relations privilégiées
avec beaucoup d'entre eux
et il y a des investisseurs
marocains qui ont suivi,
et le Maroc est devenu
un pays émergent,
et les relations entre beaucoup
de pays africains et le Maroc
sont excellentes.
-Merci, Tahar Ben Jelloun.
-Je vous en prie, merci à vous.
-Merci de vos réponses.
Générique
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA